this story seems to naturally have so
many cinematic elements to it the
underdog side of things as thrilling car
races and I imagine that there were a
lot of different incarnations throughout
the years so how long have you been
working on this project and what was the
evolution many many people tried to make
this movie including myself and Peter
Chernin all of us failed and it came
back around to us when Jim got involved
and had not only like this incredible
clarity of vision but also not to be
crass he had just you know or in the
studio gobs of money when he had made
Logan and he had a lot of leverage with
them thank you and he found his perfect
cast and at all just the time seemed
right so James what was it about this
story that made you want to come on
board not only as a director but as a
producer as well what I found the
characters I first kind of encountered
the story in in 2010-2011 I'm back when
Jenna wood and those guys were first
dancing with it and I just found the
story captivating I'm not a big motor
sports person it was just the characters
were really beautiful to me interesting
unique a unique moment in American
history and a kind of metaphor you know
the car are always in movies is kind of
a metaphor and somehow I saw in auto
racing and this effort these characters
were making I think I identified with
them a lot of levels making movies is
not all that different than getting a
car on the road and and I think that was
it I also I mean I'm not stupid I mean
the the dynamism of car racing the
beauty of those cars that was all
alluring as a backdrop in a kind of
world to put it in and in many ways
sometimes you know the thing that you
don't get like I wasn't the the I don't
I didn't get Motorsports or what was
exciting about them I make almost my
journey in the movie to get you know so
that that it's a world I don't
completely
means I have a lot to learn and that
makes that makes the trip exciting and
Christian you're no stranger to playing
real people but what were the challenges
and I guess also the pleasures of
playing Ken miles it's so much pleasure
in playing ken miles you know we were
looking at this very brief moment in in
in the life of Shelby miles and he was
such fun to play you know he that I
think that it was a real gift in ken
miles was not yes stereotypical racing
driver who was often imagined to be a
very strong silent type and unreadable
and also thank God that era had open
helmets you know so we could see the
face it makes such a huge difference
imagine all those races well and it
nothing you know I don't know does he
enjoy this or not I've got no idea you
know but but it allowed us to really
show just this absolute sort of
transcendence this joy that he gets and
really being raw and alive you know in
those moments and I'm being a quite a
kooky at times eccentric but I mean to
me absolutely adorable lovable character
I so loved playing him James am I right
in saying that you wanted Christian Bale
and Matt Damon from the very beginning
for these carrots so what was it about
them that you thought had the particular
qualities for these roles well first of
all they're both incredibly great actors
just period you know and full stop
so and and I've known them both for many
many years and and it was just I mean
you don't know anything you just have an
instinct about there being ways that
these particular very creative Souls
will connect with these characters and
with each other and I can't say I knew
it would work but I you just kind of
have a feeling the chemistry is there
the history is there you know when you
meet the characters they have this sense
of history already so Christian was that
something that you and Matt had to work
on or did you already have that
naturally we would cross paths many
times over the years in fact
my wife had worked on a film that Jim
did many many years ago and have met
Matt on that so they knew each other but
yeah I don't really conform to the whole
thing of Oh in order to act like friends
people have to be friends and go and
hang out you know in fact I would find
that really confusing because then I
would go hang out if we had done it we
didn't but if we had I would have gone
and hung out with Matt and Matt would
have really gotten to know me and then I
would have gone oh bugger now I'm on the
set I've got to be Ken miles and now I
feel like an idiot because he knows how
much I'm acting so I prefer not to get
to know the other actors that much
instead because then I can get away with
acting more and maybe they don't know
how hard I'm trying right now Christian
you're said did some driving what did
those car racing scenes require for you
and how much training did you do I got
away with the you know convincing Jim
and everybody that I needed to go do a
racing school there for it which was a
lot of fun and actually it was Bob
Bondurant racing school and you know he
was a peer of Ken miles and so I would
do the racing and I myself am Robert
Nagle the stunt coordinator we would sit
and have lunch with Bob and he would
just tell us yarns about Ken miles and
it was absolutely fantastic and you know
learned a little bit you know of when
you're actually driving and being that
close to other people and whatnot and
changed anything but I had a lot of fun
doing it and and then whenever I could
III did as much as I possibly could but
with the realization that Jim probably
wanted the race sequences to be exciting
and if I was behind the wheel I'd be
really excited but nobody else would
what kind of research materials did you
find the most helpful when it came to
understanding who Ken miles was the most
useful was his son I spent time with
Peter miles and him just chatting just
telling me stories about his dad
very moving stuff I bought I watched the
film with just Peter and Peter's
daughter Ken's granddaughter just the
three of us that was incredibly moving
to do that and he provided me with a lot
of materials and articles and there are
books you know some including Ken's some
about Ken but not much in the way of
compared to Shelby you know he did so
many different interviews Ken miles is
not much you know a few when he was
winning and he said it was odd thing I
had to make a choice because he always
sounded extremely plummy he sounded sort
of this baby changed all the voice then
going on and I my way is from the
Midlands nobody sounds like that in the
Midlands and so I kind of went okay well
maybe that was because he's on TV and he
feels like that's the way you have to
speak and Peter is is is born in America
and he wasn't able to help me with that
at all he was I have no idea where what
the accent so I sort of went okay I'll
do a better spoken Midlands Brummie
accent for him well thank you all for
being here